is Trump going to try to use the money  to support other candidates but not just  out of the goodness of his heart  conditionally in exchange for favors  support in 24 whatever that's the other  idea which is Trump will ultimately  relent and as we get closer to November  midterms now we're only uh just a you  know a little bit over three months away  Trump will start to deploy the money for  the people that he's supporting but in  exchange for vows of uh loyalty going  into 2024. let me know your thoughts  what do you think Trump's raising the  money for what do you think he's going  to use the money for but a great  question from Karl Rove where are the  donations actually going make sure that  you are following me on Twitter at  dpacman let me know where do you think  the donations are going and of course  make sure to sign up at joinpakman.com  the program is viewer supported and I  would love to have your support